[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
welcome back to the break room our daily
show that keeps you updated on all the
hot nerd news we are remote once again
got no internet at the office so we're
all internet
baby
uh we hope to have that fixed sometime
this week but we appreciate you if
you're watching uh this is not a
permanent change to the break room we'll
be back in our cool studio before you
know it uh but today we will be coming
at you remote uh and we'll be uh
covering some pretty hot updates from
wakanda forever we got some stranger
things some top gun
uh news submission impossible a lot of
stuff to cover here and with me to cover
it we've got uh
the um goose to my maverick mr tommy
beck told
hey thanks for having me zach it's great
to be here
very formal on the monday goose is the
one that dies messing around where's my
hangover gang at who's picking up the
pieces on a fine monday who went to bed
last night and said i could make some
changes and woke up feeling like [ __ ]
took two more hours of a nap and now
they're thinking about everything
they've ever done wrong if you're with
me drop some money in that super chat
yes
we'll get we'll go back to that super
chat in a second uh the um the ice man
to my maverick we've got mr brandon
barack
oh heck yeah
i'll take you down the rumors of my
demise have been greatly exaggerated i'm
still alive i'm here
back in the flesh we're happy to have
you back brandon and uh joining us once
again normally off screen currently on
screen the f16 to my maverick we've got
john costa you can ride me all day zach
no problem
a little paraphrasing
those are those are friday vibes for a
monday show okay uh monday's the new
friday baby
yeah speaking of super chats we're
rocking our our normal reverse swear jar
the the second we hit a hundred dollars
in total super chats it unlocks a swear
that uh one of the hosts can use
indiscriminately the first one that
notices it gets to drop it mid-sentence
uh otherwise we're not supposed to curse
though tommy might have dropped an
s-bomb in his interest oh i did i'm so
sorry who's counting
uh but first
the headlines
ah
um in an interview with polygon doctor
strange and loki writer michael waldron
said he's hoping the events of
multiverse of madness will make for an
even weirder season two of loki he was
quoted as saying nothing is in the movie
by accident kevin feige is certainly
aware of the implications of everything
here you know they're not spirits of the
damned just for spirits of the damned
sake if i have a penny for every time
i've heard that said
you know mean how many mcu films do you
think have accidental stuff in them like
that kevin feige didn't approve
think accidental
yeah
well well i think i don't like the term
accident because i do think like
choices were made maybe just to like
advance the plot of a single movie or to
get it done in that day shoot or
whatever without thinking long-term
applications but yeah there felt like
there was a lot of those in those early
movies right i mean i think the only
accident was that post credit from iron
man when he's like the avengers
initiative and they're like oh he
pluralized it
oh no
yes
democratically elected leader
yeah
could tommy could we hear what that
state of the union might sound like
my fellow spirits of the damned
i come before you a humble spirit of the
dams
and i admit things aren't going as well
as we'd hoped strange
thank you but that's good right things
shouldn't be going well it's like the
opposite right
yeah yeah it's like golf
lower is better
not like basketball where higher is
better why am i just turning into mark
hamill's skeleton
also rest in peace gilbert godfrey okay
uh
dr strange is the multiverse of madness
crossed the 800 million
mark at the box office worldwide box
office over the weekend uh that puts it
ahead of the batman to become the number
one comic book movie of 2022 really the
number one movie of 2022 right nothing's
beating it uh because we're counting uh
are we sure that men hasn't passed it i
saw men did pretty good over the weekend
big big jesse buckley fan over here
haven't seen that flick yet but i'm
looking forward sure morbius isn't the
top grossing film of the year top top
grossing in our heart um but uh
multiverse madness now sits just below
thor ragnarok just above the first
guardians of the galaxy movie as far as
total worldwide box office in theory
multiverse man is still growing still
has a couple more weeks of uh pulling in
some big bucks so we'll see where it
ends up in the grand scheme of things
again quite the accomplishment in kind
of still weird covid era
and crazy like kind of a crazy leap
above the first dr strange i mean i know
obviously now the character is so much
more
ingrained in our our our collective uh
marvel hearts but like i mean it's like
double what the doctor first dr strange
made or something like that like it's
crazy
uh you know all it took was a little
wand a little mother's love the love of
a mother
to make the to make the movie really
sing
uh and then
moving on to our what's on our thumbnail
for this video if that got you to click
on it so we maybe possibly kind of
got our first look at namor
uh over the weekend there's some kind of
weird
tweets of like blurry photos and like
artists
on the internet and like my mom coming
home in about 10 minutes and me just
googling cindy margolis and like trying
to get like
just having her one millimeter by
millimeter appearing on my computer and
it being completely blurry starting to
sharpen up door opening me scrambling to
pull up my umbrellas
yeah guys
the most a name i've not heard in some
time
the most downloaded woman on the
internet that was right
there yes
uh
yeah we can only hope neymar would be
the most downloaded man on the internet
at one point um but we we not only got
kind of these like artist renderings
what maybe his character might look like
uh we got an image of a rap gift for
folks that don't know anytime a movie or
tv series finishes the season or
finishes filming they give wrap gifts
like you're wrapping up to all the cast
and crew a lot of times these gets get
in the hands of low-level grips and pas
who then immediately sell them on ebay
or post photos on twitter or whatever
and this particular uh image was of a
hat a baseball cap that has a picture i
looked up the pronunciation on this i
hope i get it right it is um
um which is an aztec jaguar god
uh on the pho on the hat that's the rap
gift for
black panther to wakanda forever
interesting yeah so
we're thinking maybe this is connecting
if neymar is the main villain of black
panther too maybe they're kind of
shifting his origin
or or connecting the dots here that
the atlanteans are connected to kind of
aztec
history
okay now i i just want to give this is
actually an earnest hot tip if you are a
film aficionado or a tv initia
aficionado and you live in southern
california or new york or chicago
go to goodwill and you will find it
pristine rap gifts from all of your
favorite shows t-shirt i'm not even
kidding like i know goodwill can be a
little dicey you might get a pair of
jeans with some stains you don't
recognize but they're calvins they're
calvin's uh
a brand that has not been relevant in 25
years but uh
but i i can tell you i have found some
very i mean i found some like breaking
bad rap gifts there once like you could
get i once very hurtfully found the
middle rap gifts there and i was i
wanted to trace it back this
oh i got double gifts because i was
twice but uh anyway not to derail the
conversation but yeah
go to those goodwills and get those rap
gifts baby they belong it's not a good
will it is it is one of the fun parts of
living in southern california also
sometimes you'll see unhoused
individuals with like a csi miami yeah
t-shirt and you're like did they work on
csi miami or was that look a little
closer it's david caruso
[Laughter]
oh still taking those sunglasses off
looks like this house isn't a home
yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
um so anyways what are we
and you know this is maybe a a fuller
topic we don't have a ton of information
on on neymar his involvement in wakanda
forever we're just starting to get more
information some different cast members
and things like that are starting to
talk about it again the apparently
they've wrapped principal photography on
the film
who knows where we are as far as getting
a trailer seems like marvel really likes
to drop the trailer for its next movie
right before the premiere
of its current movie so maybe early july
we might see a trailer for this right
ahead of uh thor love and thunder who
knows um what what are you thinking
about this news surrounding neymar and
black panther 2.
so hard because it's like it's such a
i mean
throughout the scope of marvel comics a
large character but not one that's been
like immensely popular in a long time
so introducing this character is kind of
uh more of a it's like an earthbound
guardians of the galaxy it's like they
have to introduce it in an amazing way
that people don't necessarily have to be
pre-existing
submariner or neymar fans they can just
be like all right i just like this
character and what they're doing in the
movie so you know i think there's a lot
of pressure to
uh kind of stick the stick the launch
and the landing so to speak on it and uh
right now we have so little information
but i mean it's marvel so they're
probably gonna make it awesome right i
mean we can believe it yeah i know
people think i'm that we're paid by
marvel if i was i wouldn't have bare
walls
prison like set up so bear wall club
here i was really hoping there would be
like a reference to atlantis or atlanta
or
atlantis uh
in atlanta uh in um the eternals right
because in the comics the internals and
the deviants they play a big role in the
sinking of atlantis but this kind of
twist of like maybe tying them to the
aztecs is very interesting like this
kind of like old world empires and maybe
the
aztecs were like
a portion of the atlanteans that escaped
before the sinking i don't know and it
separated the two
uh
tribes something like that it's very
cool but i think you're right there's a
lot of introduction that has to be done
here a lot of pushing it away from
aquaman who kind of owns the man
underwater space as it is right now so
it'll be really cool to see what they do
and i'm i'm wondering if it'll be a
reverse of that and then the eternals
will be brought back
once neymar is introduced right like i
mean we did have
they did we did have what's his name
barry keough
messing up messing up things in south
america and central america in the movie
so you know oh interesting well in in
like like you were saying tommy both
namor right is also a different like
species right the atlanteans right this
isn't like killmonger where he's like a
special forge says guy and like you know
there was nothing necessarily
supernatural i guess other than the uh
kind of the spirituality of of the uh
black panther
uh culture right and the wakandans in
the first
um black panther uh so yeah this will be
a big i like are there an entire race of
people living under the ocean uh
somewhere
uh that that's a big that's a big jump
kind of from the conflict centered in
the first movie and i also want to say
you know this a lot of people have been
speculating about namor showing up in
this even before casting rumors got out
there because in the kind of most recent
tanahisi coats
run of comics uh of black panther comics
that a lot of the first film pulled from
heavily there's a big story arc with
neymar where he like floods wakanda like
the atlanteans and the wakandans have
like a giant war uh dr doom plays a
little role in that there's been some dr
doom whispers uh slipping out on the
internet i don't know that they're
connected to black panther forever but
um
i love doom whiskers
baby
that's like my white noise
that character in the comics has so many
connections to a lot of characters that
we've been sort of like wanting
so bad to be introduced into the mcu you
have x-men
fantastic fantastic people he's a beauty
right he's a mutant and and hopefully
that this character can sort of draw
from all sort of
corners of marvel comics and and
introduce all these folks i know we've
been saying for like years oh this is
how the fantastic four is gonna be
introduced this is how the x-men is
gonna be introduced but it feels like
the time
maybe they'll have an accident it's
bubbling up like a atlantean
uprising
all of our predictions are kindly
finally coming to fruition that's right
that's right coming up to the surface
after being buried uh long ago we'll be
coming back to uh maybe a little bit
more wakanda forever and neymar
discussion meanwhile throw your thoughts
in the chat maybe you got uh some
predictions of how he might be
introduced uh what that conflict might
be centered around is he gonna be a
mutant is there gonna be an entire race
of atlanteans how might that uh be
connected to the aztec culture throw
your thoughts in the chat we'll try to
get back to those later in the episode
moving on though and this is big news
here at new rockstars headquarters we've
been scrambling all day we got word a
second 411 thunder trailer is dropping
tonight during the nba playoffs
on network tv so we are going to uh be
scrambling to cover that
um eric voss is going to have a reaction
live on the channel pretty soon after
the trailer drops we'll have a breakdown
on the channel tomorrow
uh and we're going to come back to this
trailer topic in a few minutes
for a little
speaking of doom whispers
mandatory fun
ah
the the most doom-filled whisper you
could possibly order
that's the whistle i have to play to
keep the mandatory fun goblin from
jumping out that keeps him asleep
oh god we must we must let them get
their rest uh speaking of trailers
we got a couple other big trailers
dropped in the last 24 hours we got
after it kind of half leaked on the
internet we got a mission impossible
dead reckoning part
one yeah
that's a threat part one dead reckoning
part one so this is gonna be a two-part
dead reckoning i guess uh i don't know
that i can handle that much reckoning
with that
we were just talking before this aired
and now we all i love the mission
impossible franchise and i've seen all
the episodes but
can you
after one two three
can you name the subsequent sequels with
their subtitle in any kind of order
yes okay there's ghost there's rogue
nation
there's ghost protocol
there's
mission what was the sixth one there's a
fallout in there somewhere right that's
it right oh yeah
i think that's it follow okay rogue
nation ghost protocol fallout which one
had the chimera was that the second one
i think it was that was the john woo
rivera was the second one with uh tandy
newton in the motorcycle fight right yes
the same way i always find you magic
kicks the chimera virus up in the air
and catching oh yes yes yes baby i am
begging for it
which one had philip seymour huffman was
that two before
yeah that was the three that was the fun
one yeah yeah he like has a weird mask
technology that i want yeah yeah it's
like goofy
oh
no
yes
uh it's so good i miss him every day
philip seymour hoffman
rochester pride of fairport new york we
love you phil oh
rest in peace um but i mean this movie
looks wild like it the plot at this
point the overall franchise plot
indecipherable it's wild they just build
these movies around insane action pieces
they've kind of become the like slightly
thinking man's fast and the furious yeah
exactly
it does feel like this franchise is
rocketing toward a mars trip you know
fast and furious already did
we're gonna go to mars and we're gonna
do it for real
his name is tom cruise
and it's not the car movie
you know what i'm saying guys cruz like
a guy i don't know lay it out for me
again
like a car how have we not gotten
mission impossible cruise control
they burned that one they burned it on a
speed sequel yes that's right uh and
then we got i love they they call it
they're even saying now final trailer uh
when they release these trailers we got
a final trailer for stranger things
season four which comes out this friday
i just before we talk about this trailer
i just want to give everybody
a little heads up on the content that is
coming their way the next 10 days of
your life are going to be insane
we get
late thursday early friday we get two
episodes of obi-wan kenobi dropping
episode one and two friday night or
evening or whenever we get stranger
things season four part one which is
still like 14 hours of content or
something like that right didn't they
announce the run times of this show and
it's crazy long a lot um and it's in
it's lopsided though they are breaking
the season into two chunks the second
chunk is a much smaller chunk than the
first chunk but that last episode two
and a half hours
it's insane okay oh my god it's a long
one yeah hey i love it i love it i wish
they were not i wish they were all nine
hours ago yes every episode again how
can we complain about getting a lot of
the stuff we love and then we're just a
uh you know a week and change away from
miss marvel we'll have another obi-wan
next wednesday so in the next like 10
days we get three episodes of obi-wan uh
it's a it's a
bouquet of riches over here not to
mention the boys can't wait for eric and
i to not sleep
for
two solid nights in the calendar week
because we're up talking all we want yes
eric and tommy are going to be at star
wars celebration in anaheim california
on thursday and friday they're going to
be
going to events seeing uh maybe some
exclusive clips trying to talk to people
uh still making content we won't have
tommy probably on the breakdown at least
not live he might be sending in some
dispatches from the field we're very
excited for all the cool experiences
both of them are going to have down
there and if hey if you're down there at
star wars celebration and you see uh two
gentlemen probably masked up but who you
recognize from the
from the
foreign simply play this tune oh no
and i will answer rohan will answer yes
i i do love i did want to chat just
briefly about this stranger things final
trailer like in watching that and i
watched the previous trailer i haven't
watched the first eight minutes that
they've released because i feel like
that's a bridge too far but
it's like oh there's so much footage in
this final trailer that i hadn't seen
before like and of course because they
got so many hours of content this final
trailer looks incredible like i don't
know had it been stated before it ends
with like you know the gang goes or
everything gets turned upside down and
you see them riding their bikes in the
upside down like that is dope i'm very
it's exciting
my my my nephew james fan of the show
fan of the channel frequent appearer of
rogue theories from about two years ago
in the pandemic has reported to me today
he's now watched all three for of the
seasons five times through so if we need
him to come on and explain some stuff
through the filter of a 12 year old he's
ready well speaking of which
i'm one of those sad people who needs a
recap of every single new season of
television that i watch and whitney i'll
have you guys say it again
oh good but i was gonna say whitney is
doing a great um recap of the first
three seasons because it's been what
zach like
four i it came out before i started
working in new rock stars two and a half
years ago wait wait wait pretty pandemic
yeah yes um so i need that i'm excited
for that
yeah yeah that'll be coming out on the
channel wednesday or thursday i believe
she's kind of catch us all up remind us
of all the stuff that happened because
there's been a lot there's been a lot
yeah
great great we're very excited we'll
we'll be we'll be a busy crew this
weekend and into next week and then
basically all the way through june it's
uh first week of june we get the boys
comes back my god at the same time
hosting the boys underground no one's
reached out to me am i fired am i
rehired i'm pretty sure you're doing it
tommy
reaching out to you right now it's you i
need to go underground again come with
me everyone hear my swatto theories
so yeah at the same time there are a few
weeks we'll be getting miss marvel
obi-wan and the boys all at the same
time also we have no idea when they're
dropping rick and morty the next season
they'll probably surprise will also be
the theory is august for that but you
never know it could come earlier uh so
we're excited here on the channel
there's gonna be a lot to talk about
coming forward but one thing we want to
talk about real quick are the folks that
help us bring this show to you and today
that is athletic greens uh we want to
thank them for sponsoring the show tommy
actually has some of their product
that's the ag-1 product from athletic
greens in every scoop of ag-1 you're
absorbing 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals probiotics and other great
stuff to get your day started right and
i got to be honest in my path my eternal
quest for fitness
i have drank a thousand of these
powdered
supplement drinks this is good i could
drink this you saw i just took half of
it down it tastes good i'll be honest
with you i can look at the back there's
lots of good stuff in here
i don't know if i can drink it so anyone
can yes and in fact hopefully when we
get back in in studio we'll all have
access to some delicious uh athletic
greens again we're getting this back
this is mine now fair fair uh the
special blend of ingredients in in ag-1
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your focus
your recovery all kinds of great stuff
and as tommy kind of mentioned present
new rockstars you know we are often
up late catching premieres maybe we have
to go straight from work to a screening
we're doing that tomorrow we're going to
a screening of top gun maverick but
we'll be going you know and you got to
grab fast food or or you know uh
microwave uh something and it's tough to
feel like you're getting all the
nutrients you need in in for the day
maybe you also have similar experiences
so athletic greens is great for that
because you can feel like well i checked
a lot of my boxes here at the beginning
of the day by by slamming some ag-1 and
i know that uh no matter what i'm able
to consume the rest of the day i'm kind
of taken care of uh and
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition just one
scoop and a cup of water every day
that's all it takes that's it no need
for a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply
of immune boosting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
break room the name of this show again
that's athleticgreens.com
break room
to take ownership of your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance it also helps us out here at
the show we appreciate athletic greens
we appreciate you folks that use that
link all right we also of course want to
promote um
oh actually you know what i want to
promote new rockstars is on tumblr i've
mentioned this a few times before uh
some folks watching maybe you've been on
tumblr in the past maybe you're a
current person on tumblr but you're
there for interior decorating tips or
um supernatural memes or whatever it
might mean
find us on tumblr it's new rockstars
official we made a lot of really cool
moon night content jessica clemens is on
there going off yeah she's very excited
to just kill on it yeah yes she's very
excited about ms marvel she's like done
a lot of comics research and tumblr is
like a great place for her to kind of
like post those screenshot comparisons
and cool stuff like that so follow us on
tumblr if you're not already uh it's
going to be really cool especially built
around miss marvel now
tommy i
almost awakened a demon earlier and
you played your magic flute to keep that
demon asleep but
might might be that time time for time
for what
time for
mandatory fun
it's time for mandatory fun
play it again
yes it's time for mandatory fun
this
segment's so nice we play the graphic
twice
that segment's so icy sometimes we play
it thricey hit that graphic
again
that's right it's the segment that's
never a snore so sometimes we henceforth
play it four hit that graphic again
this is abuse this is abuse
all right it's time for mandatory fun
where i get three absolute
undisputed best friends in the whole
wide world
for a little bit
of non
uh
optional enjoyment with me so today
we're talking thor love and thunder
thor love and thunder trailer coming out
tonight so we have no other choice but
to make some predictions but i don't
want us to just
get out there and do some rogue
predictions or ask some big questions or
go inside marvel or you know wookie leak
out some information or
you know even go underground with the
boys on this one i want us to make
i want you to explain
about
the trailer coming up i want each one of
you to make one safe prediction and i
want you guys to make one
what
prediction one out there prediction and
then i professional handicapper
degenerate gambler and someone who wants
bet
three dollars on a 12-letter parlay and
had to pay out 497.com
before it was shut down by the fbi
company
in the form of a check it took a few
weeks to get to my house that's not
clear baby i'm the greatest gambler of
all time that will be handicapping
because each one of you has told me you
will bet 20
of your own real money yeah
one of these predictions that we hear
henceforth so got it right here a prop
i'll give away the serial number on
stream
all right download use that download
code guys call us
call in if you encounter that now all
right and don't forget to hit that super
chat guys we know that times are tough
and that
gas is 94 a gallon but wouldn't you like
to hear me say the f word once
all right who wants to go first with a
safe prediction safe i got i got a safe
prediction
okay i've been i've been noodling on
this ever since you announced uh what we
were gonna have to do
uh this is a prediction i made for the
first one but i wanna repurpose it
because i think it's going to come
through you know we had a sweet child of
mine as the song
for the first trailer okay i think
they're not going to reuse that song i
think they want a fresh song
uh this is thor love and thunder so i
think this trailer is gonna use
meatloafs
anything for love wow i think they're
gonna use it this time
they're gonna use that they want the
nostalgia they want the rock
and i would do
anything
[Music]
beautiful beautiful sounds here's what
i'm thinking
we got the
you know classic rock throwback in the
last trailer i think we're going to make
the tone a little more serious okay
it's going to be somber to start we've
got gore the god butcher coming into
this movie
and similar to i was re-watching the
trailer for captain america civil war
the other day because it's just so good
um and similar to how that movie ends
with iron man taking roadie's helmet off
after he's plummeted i think we're gonna
have
something that we don't quite know what
it is when we're watching the trailer
but i think we're gonna see a character
that we love
right before their death in the eventual
movie and i think it's going to be
valkyrie someone said on the break room
the other day that they thought valkyrie
might not make it it was tommy
and i think we're going to see
some
she's got a sacrifice she's she's king
valkyrie now she's making a sacrifice i
think we're going to see
the very early moments of her death in
this trailer
that's your safe place that's safe wow
i feel really good kind of like kind of
like how we kind of maybe saw aunt may's
pre-death a little in the spider-man one
yeah we saw her apparel we saw her in
peril yes um okay well i'm gonna play it
both these guys yeah coming out of the
gate not feeling very safe for the safe
prediction so i'm gonna play it very
safe we're going to get our first
official look
at christian bale score the god bless
you
come on that's something that's
guaranteed that's what i was asking for
i think a fade to black and then uh
gods have had it all for way too long
someone needs to bring the gods to their
knees
is someone moving in my eye line who's
moving
[Music]
welsh is tough welsh is tough okay so
now we've all got our three
all right everybody i had to save
predictions and here's how i run it
here's how i run it meatloafs i would do
anything for love i'm putting that at
four to one odds that's four to one odds
for meatloaf i would do anything for
love now
uh
i'm sorry just got a slack from dodson
that kind of threw me off my game no
problem dots it uh
that's my fault i got to be more of a
professional next thing next thing we
got valkyrie's death being teased i'm
putting that at eight to one johnny
eight to one odds coming in home finally
we got the first appearance of glory the
god butcher i got that heavy favorite at
one to two that's right you got about
two dollars to win one dollar for gordon
god butcher it just seems like a shoe-in
at this point now let's get to those
risky predictions
okay
you should go in reverse order this time
though right that's nice
i
my risky prediction is
you know in the previous
trailer we saw what we think is russell
crowe as zeus from the back
right kind of like waving his arms to
the crowd i think in this one i'm kind
of building off of my safe prediction we
see gore the god butcher holding
zeus's severed head that's so fun
god
i love that prediction
that's excellent all right um okay
you're using the same order since
there's only three that's right i
i don't feel good about this prediction
at all um
but you know we're here i think what
we're gonna do we're gonna see
a character that we were not expecting
to be in this movie yet we saw
a little tease of bast in that photo i'm
thinking maybe we get some characters
from black panther wakanda forever i
think maybe
somehow
we see
a shuri or a killmonger in an ancestral
plane or something wild like that
i don't i don't know how that would
happen in the trailer but that's that's
where i'm leaning
i like it daddy likey
all right brandon ugh i kind of had a
cameo too for my my risky one we like
cameo you like came out i got a very
specific cameo because i really thought
about this one okay i i see where john's
going with this they like to maybe pop
in another mcu character to get your
your interest peaked you know what i
mean uh kind of like how we we got to
see hulk in thor ragnarok even though he
was a big part of that one we saw a
star-lord and the the guardians in this
yeah yeah we see them i think there's
going to be one out of like nowhere that
we're not going to expect and i was
trying to think of who could be i was
narrowing down my options i think we
will see walking around new asgard with
his family doing a little tour
we're gonna see scott lang aka ant-man
hanging out news asgard maybe a little
bobby king of valley maybe he's there
too no he's taking the whole family
they're all walking around seeing new
asgard but that's my risky pick i think
we'll see like a comedic mcu cameo i
think it'll be ant-man i think he's he's
a safe one to throw in that doesn't
really change up everything
unfortunately you're all wrong it's
going to be an odin and frigga cameo
confirmed oh the dead baby
all right here's how i scored these
ricky risky predictions we got a seventh
juice head held by gordon god butcher at
12-1 odds 12-1 odds for that we got
wakanda cameos forever coming in at 16
to 1 odds i got that at 16-1 odds and
finally ant-man doing a little window
shopping at a at a troll shop in new
asgard i got that at 15 to 1. score that
at 15 to 1 odds now gentlemen place your
bets
also i want to shout out tommy's larry
merchant with voice i feel like i'm
watching hbo boxing in 1997. it's
wonderful um
oh well and now and we said before that
actually you can place a bet on other
people's predictions yeah yeah you can
you can distribute your 20 however you
like
i'm going to
i kind of like i like john's risky
bet i'm going to put five dollars on and
we're just saying a cast member from the
wakandan of some of some form five
dollars on wakandan cameo in the trailer
in the trailer and then i'll put
a 10 on my safe bet because i i'm
i'm i'm playing it safe here i'm going
to say god bless it
and then
and then my final five on my risky bet
of we see a dead or a head beheaded zeus
we got three bets in play three bits and
play for zach huddleston could be a
massive payout or that could be oh in
the bank a lot of money all right john
what are your bets um
similar to zach i'm gonna split uh
on two on two different predictions zach
two bets for john okay i think there's
no question that we're gonna see gore
the god butcher in this trailer we have
to see him so i'm gonna put ten dollars
on zach's
risky prediction uh that we're gonna see
him first appear with zeus's severed
head i love that i think that would be
so funny
and by the way that would pay off taiko
ytt's exclamation that this is a russell
crowe performance we've never seen him
has he ever lost his head in a movie we
know he's been stabbed to death we know
he's jumped off a bridge i believe but i
do not think we've ever seen him be
beheaded good good yeah um and then i'm
gonna put my final ten dollars on my
safe prediction which in comparison is
now starting to sound a little risky of
valkyries moments from death uh
hopefully it's her if it's another
character i'll be very disappointed but
i think it'll be her last few moments of
valkyrie's life coming in as your safe
yet risky action bets for john will he
see riches or will he see rags only
tonight's trailer drop will tell us the
truth brandon what are your wages today
okay i gotta put five dollars on my own
bet that will hear anything for love i
got five love tune
anything i got
if they play bad out of hell you will
not be paid out the house only
guarantees anything for love
uh i also got five dollars on a ant-man
cameo
scott lang and possibly bobby canaval
in new asgard if they show up anywhere
else but you as god the house will not
pay out uh two for gore the guy butcher
to pay for my parking
two dollars on the god butcher to pay
one dollar and then uh eight dollars for
valkyrie dad i kind of like that uh
total bats one on a valkyrie being dead
one uncle the god butcher one on the
lang family and one on a meatloaf tune
the bets are in boys all sales are final
we'll see you tomorrow at the payouts
this has been mandatory fun the segment
that keeps us alive so many times
sometimes we play the graphic for five
hit my graphic again
oh
what a performance oh a lot of
performances
i love you guys both going all in on uh
valkyrie getting killed
not that he has final say in this but i
taika waititi i think would like to keep
uh tessa thompson around as much as
possible if uh
some rumors uh
most definitely uh oh i wanna i want a
quick shout out a couple folks in the
chat um alejandro rodriguez saying could
the mystery illuminati member be nick
fury i like that thought that's
been in that empty seat maybe maybe even
the 838 nick fury was off world in a in
a sword space station possibly uh fray
girl saying can we refer to brandon and
john as on-screen producers now
you know
off-screen's a state of mind than it is
it's a tax haven baby don't take away my
tax haven even when i was off screen i
demanded to be on camera tommy and they
people were pretty supportive of that
and then uh johnny strickland 24 thank
you for the super chat sir uh saying not
marvel related but
chip and dale did with space jam 2
wanted to surprisingly a pretty dang
good movie we've got a breakdown for it
on our channel right now did it come out
yeah yeah yes uh as soon as we're done
live here hop on over and watch that
breakdown eric put together with with
whitney's help and a lot of other folks
trying to spot all the 100 plus cameos
in that film this is something we
casually talk a lot about around the
office too is that if there are things
that you're on the fence about watching
pop on the breakdown watch the first
couple minutes if you're intrigued great
go turn off the breakdown watch the
movie if you
don't want to watch the movie
watch the breakdown get all got all the
information you need from that breakdown
absolutely i've i've been known to do
that before in my life you'll get all
the big plot details the fun bits any
any cameos you might have missed yes we
know where you don't want to watch the
breakdown go to youtube and watch the
music video for mariah carey's song
breakdown
however you can't do that how about
you're gonna watch that and not not uh
tom petty and the heartbreakers
breakdown from 1984. um yeah you're
right and then some some hot fire in the
super chats here stanky the cat saying i
did the costumes here in l.a it's neymar
another potential costume leak or just
going off the vibes i don't know stinky
the cat i i would uh i hope i hope
that's not your legal name
because you might oh no i i once did a
wardrobe fitting with stanky the cat it
was behind an in-n-out burger
in chatsworth uh stanky rolled up in a
old shag carpeted van and i i went in
there and tried on about 45 different
outfits while uh well well they took
pictures you hadn't even booked anything
though no the weird thing is they called
a pay phone and i just picked up and
they said tommy and i was like stanky
and they're like i'll be behind the
in-n-out burger chatsworth you'll see
the van the door will fly open you'll
see the carpet unmistakable and i'll be
honest i took about a probably about a
thousand photos that day and a few a few
videos as well which is weird for a
fitting they normally don't do a video
but stanky was insistent
we want to see how it moves on yeah i
gotta watch i gotta watch your
midsection make sure it's stable
oh
thank you the cat maybe maybe you're
letting some slip thank you the cat if
you're if you're a real industry insider
and you want to reach out with uh
anything else new rockstars inc
gmail.com is our official business
address um okay brandon you have a break
room breakdown you wanted to get into
uh yeah we're gonna talk a little bit
about what eric uh brought up on the
channel today but we might say that for
tomorrow i think
we've been having too much fun here on
the breakdown
a little tease a little tease there's a
great video uh eric put out about some
mix of uh the 838 universe and what the
x-men there might have been up to we'll
talk about that tomorrow on the
breakdown
well i mean we got to make money here on
the break then in the break room isn't
that true uh tyrannosaurus bex had a
super chat that i found very interesting
um they mentioned can we take a minute
to acknowledge the people that were
blipped while riding in an airplane that
came back only to plummet to their
deaths hashtag reigning men also women
are allowed on airplanes i've i've i've
had a lot of conversations about this
like spear air it's really nice
you gotta you gotta be anatomically male
to get on the planet get out of here
they always that's the only airport
where you have to get patted down there
are no you can't just walk through a
check they gotta pat you down it's
really nice though complimentary drinks
spirit airline is that is goldberg the
pilot thing yeah
and he's just spearing people up and
down the aisles
there is a jackhammer as you land sorry
brandon oh it's okay there was a bs
answer that the i believe the uh the
russos gave about this where they said
yeah well when hulk does his snap to
bring back everybody
uh in his mind he's saying bring him
back safely or the the intention behind
it is to bring everyone back in a safe
way so people who are up in the air
there's also the things they consider
that the earth is not in the same spot
of space that it was when the blip
happened so people would just be blipped
into a random sound of space i've also
theorized like what if you were having
surgery when you were blipped dude you
come back and your body still be open
what if you had been giving birth what
if you were giving birth what if you've
been stabbed by a knife and you blipped
and you come back and now you have a
knife
all these things what if someone had
built a building where you were standing
when you were blipped but the russos
have said that people were brought back
safely which is such a bs what if you
were one of some people
what if you were at an orgy half the
people disappeared from the orgy the
other half completely turned their lives
around okay they completely turned their
lives around became different people
those five years blip reverses the
orgies back on
50 less powerful do you continue or do
you go and try and find your mom and dad
and your rest your family i don't know i
mean i think the real the real horror
and the real darkness does exist and the
people who got remarried during the play
oh yeah the people who were happy to get
away from their abusive partners during
the flip and now they're back like
that's the real darkness but if you were
in jail and you were blipped away and
you blew back you have to serve the
remainder of your sentence i don't know
yeah there would be a that would be a
fun comic series of like
like uh like private investigators who
like clean up people's blipped lives
like where they're like i like my old
life can you like can you keep keep this
person away from me or can you like sew
up this loose end or fix this problem
for me we actually did take someone out
we did a really early episode of big
question on sort of
blippications and all the weird
questions that this question poses um
that you should check out but another
thing that could be interesting is if if
hulk blipped everyone back safely does
that mean that like people with cancer
who got dusted and came back now like
somehow are healed all these ailments
that people had do you still have yeah
yeah do you think that they would be
also but if you had a stomach parasite
right did the parasite also get blipped
inside of you and it comes back
and here's the crazier thing to think
about is that this happened throughout
the universe right there are plenty of
planets where people had no idea what
was going on they didn't know about
thanos they don't know about infinity
stones they don't know anything so
they're just on their planet one day
half the people disappear and five years
later half these people come back and
they have no idea what it means it would
create chaos on that planet like
religious chaos do you think there would
have been some like avengers
outreach
you know people on earth trying to send
messages to people being you know
captain marvel was like off planet
flying around yeah but there are planets
that are not uh advanced enough to have
communication with like other planets
and and the grand galaxy federation or
whatever it's called in the mcu nova
core i guess for lack of a better
what are you going to say charm
i'll just say do you think the show the
big bang theory exists in marvel 616 and
like how were they able to keep churning
out joker 30 every 30-second comedy
after thanos split like were they just
like did they show up to work the next
day and they're like well
jim parsons blipped
kaylee cuoco's still here
johnny galecki is still here simon
kinberger not simon kinberg simon
whatever his name is still here
uh the other guy's still here got it the
one guy that's a person of color of
course i can't remember my um
still here miami alex still here
uh
you know the whole gang most of them
didn't blip chuck lori did blip though
unfortunately we know for a fact we know
for a fact that the the big bang theory
exists in the mcu because if you don't
remember uh in the black first black
panther movie killmonger actually says
bazinga right before he that's right
that's right he does that cousin off the
the water he's like i love that show
uh and on that note um
rest in peace chuck laurie snapped
before your time um we want to thank
everybody for watching today uh another
uh break room from home as live as ever
but a little bit more remote than ever
again we're probably gonna be in a
similar situation tomorrow and wednesday
we hope you'll join us we'll probably be
making some tweaks along the edges but
then fingers crossed thursday we're back
in studio for the rest of eternity um a
lot of folks working behind the scenes
to get that figured out but we thank you
for your patience we thank you for
watching
check out that chip and dale's breakdown
that just dropped on uh the new
rockstars channel oh yeah yes
and uh not not chippendales but chip and
dates
and uh we leave you with this musical
interlude from tommy bechdel
turtle
[Music]
you